I'm good welcome to the Teen Vogue in
Hollywood party I'm gonna jump right
into the Riverdale of it all though
because when is chick coming back you
said he is coming back we know he's
coming back I don't know what I can and
can't say right now is to show so
secretive so I don't want to give
anything away I think that publicly
there have been some comments by
different people really wanting me back
and saying that I was coming back and
we'll see what do you think happened to
check when he was left running from the
black hood he just see how fast he was I
mean he was pretty fast I think he's
been training a lot like he's been
putting some some weight on
he's been beefing up honing in on his
defense goes because someone was trying
to kill him it's definitely not dead
though I wouldn't mess with him he's
number one he's target number one do we
feel like Archie and chick are gonna
have because I feel like Archie's really
been beefing up to I think wait
KJ keep teasing a bromance over here
I've drawn some muscles yeah let's do it
is this what all the beefing up is about
we'll see yeah you think that chick has
anything to do with The Gargoyle King I
think you can't count check out of
anything I think that's the the best
part about chick is you think you got
him for a second then you're like what's
happening what is it you know so
even though this season I'm trying I
think so have you been on set you're the
worst
I can't say do you we think that maybe
chickens found love or will he find love
I hope yesterday was Valentine's Day hop
in your real life
Oh God
we'll see just the bromance with KJ yeah
that's all there's just pure love with
that what do you think what do you think
about Chad Michael Murray joining the
show love Chad Michael Murray yeah
Salman's to work with him huh almost got
me no do you love him
I do really like him like his worker as
a person I can't I can't
okay what do you like about him we'll
ask you that I just always thought he
had such a on
just like a calm confidence just how he
talks and acts and like I was just
always like that person does everything
with intention and I like that yeah it
should were to come back soon do you
feel like he wants revenge on anybody
[Music]
as we saw last season I think he holds
on to things we heard some of that we
saw some of that but I think there's
possibility of a new leaf I think he
wants to be good I've said that from the
beginning he wants to be good he really
does see a good side of him maybe should
should he come back should he come back
I think so
[Music]